with a new baldur's gate 3 cinematic to
get excited over I consulted the fine
folk at Larian and did a bunch of D&D
digging to break down all those sweet
nuggets of law in the new cinematic the
first thing we see is a reference to the
mind flayers grand design which is the
mind flayers plan for rebuilding their
lost Empire that was overtaken by the
key on key as well as on the left a
carving of a nautiloids those rare
flying ships of mind flayers capable of
travel between worlds and the astral
plane as well as what appears to be an
elder brain in the background which is
the powerful final stage of a mind
flayer lifecycle the other brains are
made up of the many brains of long-dead
mind flayers with the combined minds
creating an incredible intellects these
are heavily guarded entities that are
usually housed in a brine filled pool
with in mind flayer cities where they
would guide the inhabitants with psychic
dreams of illicit domination at the
center appears to be in allah Thurid or
enlightened one these are considered
Nobles of mind flayer society and
treated as minor gods by the in
comparison normal members of Allah third
society which we can see bowing before
the tentacle faced entity this chamber
is something the mind flayers used to
confer beings into other mind flayers
with the sense peace being a brine pool
housing the tadpoles that are used to
infect the brain of mortals through a
process called Sarah morphosis more on
that shortly
now mind flayers are psionic creatures
meaning they can influence not only the
minds of lesser beings but also the
world around them which in this case
comes in the form of telekinesis or
levitation
[Music]
this appears to be an elder brains brain
pool with a mine Flair tadpole to store
it
these small burrowing creatures are
usually only selected after surviving
for one decade in the pool before then
being introduced to its new host and
starting the ceremony Vyas baldur's gate
3 cinematic we saw an extremely
accelerated version of Serra more forces
taking place over moments or as it
usually takes around a week for the
tadpole to devour a host brain and the
physical changes to begin to take place
here however we take our first look at
the gift Yankee lies L one of the main
characters in the story of baldur's gate
3 as well as being one of the potential
player characters or companions
dominations madness there was a voice it
promised to change us lies L has been
taken from a gift Yankee crash this is
where they are brought up from eggs and
trained as warriors to become an adult
and enter into the wider community a
gift Yankee must conclude their training
by killing a mind flayer and presenting
their skull to the Queen black a--the we
have been told however these aren't your
regular run-of-the-mill mind flayer
tadpole instead having something very
special about them now this is just
speculation but according to wider D&D
law rare oleifera tadpoles can appear
eventually forming one of those nobles
we mentioned before whether this is the
case with these tadpoles in particular
though we don't yet know when the game
releases it will launch you into your
character creator as this screen fades
to black giving you the opportunity to
choose who just met such a Quisling fate
before the cutscene continues the pods
that are surrounding this room actually
contain all of the other potential
player characters or companions that you
will encounter in baldur's gate 3 the
dead mind flayers on the ground may
hints at some combat that has already
been taking place and that your
abduction is an effort to regrow the
mind flayer ranks and replace their
losses
[Music]
and here we see the first appearance of
the nautiloids that you are aboard in
the current D&D universe nautiloids are
extremely rare and the mind flare race
has actually lost the secrets of
constructing new nautiloids so it
appears that things are desperate for it
to appear in such conditions especially
considering that this one in particular
is much larger than most rumors exists
that the larger ones known as
dreadnaughts function as mobile layers
for mind flayers although it is not yet
clear if this one in particular fits
that bill now the city below is in fact
not bald as gate during our
behind-the-scenes look the team at
Larian wants to make this very clear but
it is in fact this city of Yatta Yatta
is described as being densely populated
to the point of overcrowding which may
go some way in explaining why the mind
flayers thought this would be a good
target to start abducting more specimens
to convert what makes the Otters
location interesting though is that it's
just east of Neverwinter and a little
ways north of baldur's gate which may
suggest the boulders game may not be the
only location in the virtual franchise
that we will get to revisit from what I
understand after talking to some of the
fine folk behind the game this
nautiloids modified tentacles that can
be used to teleport its prey into the
interior cells ready for their tadpoles
to be so gruesome Lee inserted into
their brains which may again suggest
that this is a desperate attempt for the
mind flayers to expand before the north
side can create too much havoc though we
see just what has been pursuing the
giant shut of a ship as some red dragons
and their riders appear through a nearby
portal one thing to keep in mind in the
world of Dungeons & Dragons is that each
color and type of dragon has their own
allegiances and alignments with these
red dragons in particular having a pact
with the gift Yankee that goes back as
far as the first edition for anyone that
may be new to the world of D&D or
Boulder's gates it's important to
remember that red dragons are not the
only type in the world to name just a
few more there are acid breathing black
dragons the Lightning breathing blue
dragons and the ice viewing white
dragons as well as even dozens more
[Music]
now in order to escape the mind flayers
north lloyd is forced to use its ability
to teleport through planes in what seems
to be a vain attempt at preventing
anymore tentacles from being bitten off
[Music]
[Music]
regardless of lies l being goth Yankee
or not so the red dragon seems
determined to rid the world of this wall
of tadpoles but as the nautiloids a
second teleport to escape this will mark
the beginning of the baldur's gate 3
campaign' as lies l freeze the character
from the mind flayer pod which i've been
told will start off the ingame tutorial
and your journey into Baltar's gate 3 so
that's pretty much everything in a
cinematic covered if there's anything
I've missed or a theory that you have
please leave it in the comment section
below and if you want more baldur's gate
3 content to get excited over you can
check out the chats I had with Mike
mihari after we got to see a few hours
the game play it out live in front of us
as always you can get everything you
need on a youtube channel or on GameSpot
calm
you